now when I was 15 years old I had a very
important person my life come to me and
say who's your hero and I said I don't
know I got to think about that give me a
couple of weeks I come back two weeks
later this person comes up and says
who's your hero I said I thought about
it you know who it is I said it's me in
10 years
so I turned 25 10 years later that same
person comes to me and goes so are you a
hero and I was like not even close no no
no she said why I said because my heroes
me at 35. so you see every day every
week every month and every year of my
life my Hero's always 10 years away I'm
never going to be my hero I'm not going
to attain that I know I'm not and that's
just fine with me because that keeps me
with somebody to keep on chasing
so to any of us whatever those things
are whatever it is we look up to
whatever it is we look forward to and
whoever it is we're chasing to that I
say Amen don't half ass it well that
never goes out of style does it
I mean think about it if you're gonna do
something if you've chosen to do
something whatever it is easy hard
if you give it your all and you don't
half-ass it
win lose draw get what you want don't
get what you want whatever the outcome
is
if you don't half-ass it at least you're
not gonna have to wonder
oh
would the outcome have been different
what if I did give it my all wondering
that is what keeps us up at night
life is not easy it is not don't try to
make it that way life's not fair it
never was it isn't now and it won't ever
be do not fall into the Trap the
entitlement trap of feeling like you're
a victim you are not get over it and get
on with it and yes most things are more
rewarding when you break a sweat to get
them see happiness
happiness demands a certain outcome it
is result Reliant
and I say if happiness is what you're
after then you're going to be let down
frequently and you're going to be
unhappy much of your time Joy is not a
choice it's not a response to some
result
constant
Joy is the feeling that we have from
doing what we are fashioned to do no
matter the outcome so the question that
we've got to ask ourselves is what
success is to us what success is to you
is it more money that's fine I got
nothing against money maybe it's a
healthy family maybe it's a happy
marriage maybe it's to help others to be
famous to be spiritually sound to leave
the world a little bit better place than
you found it continue to ask yourself
that question now your answer may change
over time and that's fine
but do yourself this favor
whatever your answer is don't choose
anything that will jeopardize your soul
prioritize who you are who you want to
be and don't spend time with anything
that antagonizes your character if life
was nothing but green lights and we
didn't have yellows and reds things that
make us pause hardships crises times for
introspection then what the hell would
it all be for we need the yellows and
the Reds
that's how we evolve that's how
hopefully there's some Ascension to our
being that's how we give some credit to
time and growing older if we were the
same person today that we were 20 years
ago then what are we really doing in
this life what's it really all about
what's it really matter to show where we
failed if anything I would say to my 50
year old self Go fail more
anything I would say to you go fail more
forget them those people on the
sidelines that are saying the thumbs
down are calling you something or being
snarky they're on the sidelines for a
reason we're all destined to have to do
the thing that we fear the most anyway
at some point so give your obstacles
credit and you will want
find the courage to overcome them or you
will too see more clearly that they're
not really worth prevailing over so be
brave have courage and when you do
you get stronger you get more aware you
get more respectful
of yourself and that which you fear
then you want to be a lawyer at one
point was that part of your path that
was that's what I thought I was going to
do in life then I remember my dad one
day saying he was in the oil business
and it all went under an 82 and right
around that time he was like I may need
you to be a lawyer to take care of me
anyway I went to University of Texas was
headed towards I want to be a criminal
defense lawyer and then it was around my
beginning of my junior year
where I just wasn't sleeping well with
the idea of graduate go four more years
law degree get out at 28 make an imprint
in society and you're already 30. I
didn't want to miss my 20s really trying
to practice whatever it was I want to do
then switch my path went to film school
I think we also we get caught up so
often in short-term games and short-term
return choices that give us short-term
return on our own investment us and
we don't we're not making choices that
are that are going to buy us delayed
gratification not only longer in this
life but after we're gone for our kids
and their great our grandkids and our
great great grandkids it's all a process
is is what I'm hearing from that I'm
choosing to take that line it's all
across enjoy the process you do not ever
get there that's the point that keeps
you the game because if you got there
the game's over
I find that most of the times our
obsession with what is wrong just ends
up breeding more wrong more failure the
easiest way to dissect success is
through gratitude giving thanks for that
which we do have for what is working
appreciating the simple things we
sometimes take for granted we give
thanks for these things and that
gratitude reciprocates
creating more to be thankful for it's
really simple and it works and I'm not
saying be in denial
of your failures now we can learn from
them too but only if we look at them
constructively as a means to reveal what
we are good at what we can get better at
what we do succeed at I need some
resistance yes you know and look and I
think there's very healthy ways to
create resistance in our lives when we
are on so-called Easy Street yeah that
may be not challenging ourselves in the
right way you know that we need to
create resistance to overcome it to feel
most alive but there's also foolish
times to to create resistance and the
fact of that is things are going so well
you think that's how it's going to be
for the rest of your life no trust me
the uphill's coming the drama the real
drama is coming don't create any false
drama in front of you right now because
you're kind of patronizing yourself the
real drama is going to come someone is
going to get sick you are going to get
hurt something will happen in your life
the world will do unto you or you'll do
it unto yourself so don't trip yourself
running downhill and face plant and
break your freaking nose just because
you needed some resistance running
downhill
unbelievable all right it's my least
favorite word I think we should wipe it
out of the dictionary why what's so
unbelievable about
tragedy about Triumph about people that
that raise us up or let us down it
happens every single day
we shouldn't think that the most
beautiful sunset or the greatest play or
the greatest love of our life or the
greatest moment of euphoria is
unbelievable believe it it's happening
right in front of you in you we
shouldn't feel like the greatest tragedy
of death or earthquakes or or natural
disasters or loss is unbelievable it's
part of life too believe it we see it
happen every day awesome
horrible
incredible
I believe those but unbelievable nah
it's just that
believe it to actually have true Freedom
we have to be responsible more
responsible for certain things for
ourselves who we are constantly
investigating and interrogating our
better selves to say I'm going to be a
little bit better at this tomorrow
knowing that we Never Land we never we
never there's no there's no ta-da moment
and that is one thing I think we all got
to watch because we all are so result
oriented oh if I keep doing this I'm
gonna get to that place of pure
Enlightenment but there's no tadam we're
always chasing yet and if we can get
comfortable and understand and laugh at
and and be ready to work hard at the
fact that
we're all just if we could just say
we're all just achieving our way to the
unachievable and that's as good as it
gets